foreign
[Music]
welcome everybody
see you
I'm Alexander Rosen the executive
director here at long now but I first
met Jenny O'Dell I think when she was uh
the artist in Residence at the what
people call the SF dump or the landfill
and it was you know she was doing these
insane collages and really great
Observatory work on what we often think
of as trash or what we what we often
think of as the mundane and she has made
us a career now out of observing the
things right around herself and I
believe the the proposal for this book
was done before the the pandemic but of
course the pandemic made for a perfect
moment to observe the things closest to
us and so it's been amazing to kind of
watch her career and make a real study
out of that because it's so uh apropos
along now the conversation and the rest
of her talk that we're going to have
tonight so Jenny O'Dell thank you
thank you so much for being here thank
you to the long now for hosting me and
besides the fact that there's a lot of
overlap between what I write about in my
book and the type of thinking that the
long now does this event is really
meaningful for me because my work is
very based in the Bay Area and this is
the Bay Area Institution
this is also only the third in-person
event I've done since the beginning of
the pandemic so I'm just so glad that we
could all be here together this book
published today which means I've been
doing a lot of interviews and one of the
questions that I get asked is why I
chose to write about time
and I've been finding it a little bit
hard to answer that because I don't feel
like I ever really chose it or I don't
remember choosing it perhaps the best
way to explain my choice is with this
image from the photographer Alan
grinberg who lives in Pacifica and was
kind enough to let me use this in my
conclusion in the book he took this
during the king Tides a couple years ago
I wrote this book for the same reason
that I wrote how to do nothing which is
that I needed it in this case as a
person who feels crushed by the pressure
between now and not now
it's true that I have a cerebral
interest in time I think most of us do
but with that alone I never would have
written this I never would have tried to
write my way out of a bind that felt
very real
this book is my sincere attempt to
recover an appetite for the future and
someone who lives squeezed between Daily
Time scarcity climate Despair and the
knowledge of their own mortality
in the introduction I call it my
panoramic assault on nihilism
so and the title saving time has a
double meaning I want to think through
how more people could have more time by
which I really mean more control over
their time but I also want to think
about saving senses of time the same way
you would think of a seed bank
and one very significant sense of time
that I want to save is time that's not
simply additive but alchemical where no
moment is the same and each is capable
of transfiguring the past all at once
and In This Moment In which so much
seems deadening and inevitable it's that
quality of possibility that I'm trying
to save so I said that my work is based
in the Bay area that is more literally
the case with this book than how to do
nothing I organized the book chapterwise
as a one day out and back road trip from
Oakland to the Pacific coast and back
and then each of the chapters is set in
a location where that type of time or
understanding of time is especially
visible so just to run through them
really quickly the industrial time I
talk about at the Oakland port
problems with time management self-help
and a traffic jam on 880 probably very
familiar to some of you I feel like
people in New York will not understand
that um
a Leisure at the Stanford Shopping
Center and a nearby Open Space Preserve
ecological and geological time at a
beach in Pescadero
climate dread at the part of Pacifica
that is especially hard hit by erosion
different communal languages of time at
the prillinger library finally the time
of one's own life I.E mortality at the
Chapel of the Chimes and its neighboring
cemetery and in doing this I'm making
use of a very old story technology one
where it's easier to remember the
different parts of the story later if
you can travel the root in your head so
like cynically I'm just trying to help
you remember what's in the book but
I also wanted it to be a trip where you
returned to the beginning because I'm
very obsessed with the feeling of
returning to something with new
knowledge a process that also represents
time and the fact that we are always
learning and experiencing even if we
think we're in the same place
and I also did this to show the reader
that we can easily find material
evidence of the seemingly abstract and
historical ideas I'm describing that we
can find them in the concrete every day
that time and history have made the
material and cultural world we live in
and that by extension what we do now is
historical
so I don't have time tonight to take you
on this entire road trip I thought I
would just drop into a couple of points
along the way and hopefully inspire you
to take the entire Journey on your own
so as I said the very first chapter
begins at 7 A.M at the Oakland port and
so they're sort of like italicized
interludes in the book that imagine that
you and I are in my car from high school
which has no AUX input or power windows
or anything it's just you're just a car
so and that we're like you know driving
through the Oakland Port thinking about
industrial time I chose this setting
because it gives us such a striking view
of standardization and by extension it's
kind of a visual metaphor for how time
appears when we think of time as money
like the container system the
standardization of time and the notion
of equal interchangeable hours that
could be run through a system happened
in a very specific moment involving
Commerce colonialism and the need to
measure others labor
and I think it's worthwhile keeping this
history in mind when we consider the
current stickiness of the notion that
time is money
there's a really incredible book called
the colonization of time by Giordano
Nani that I cite quite a bit of in that
chapter where he describes the encounter
between the British colonial sense of
time and the existing understandings of
time among people living in colonized
places and this encounter was not a
straightforward takeover you get
situations where for example the Sabbath
punctuated week only extends as far as
the audible range of the Mission Bell
but I want to read a little excerpt that
Nani gives us from a late 19th century
publication it's from a South African
Mission and it's essentially a piece of
cultural propaganda about time
how much have you in the bank not the
Savings Bank that would be a good thing
for you to have a little there too this
bank is a better one perhaps you have
nothing to put in the Savings Bank and
you think you have nothing to put in any
other you are wrong you may be putting
money in every day did you ever count up
how much or how little you had got there
in the Bank of which God is the manager
and over whose counterpass the well-used
moments of each day and all the good
things a man thinks or says or does we
speak of spending time time spent does
not go into the bank any more than money
spent but every moment you use well for
god you put into the bank I would advise
you to all to put something in to put in
all you can for the bank gives good
interest
um so I think this excerpt kind of gives
you some idea of how deeply the notion
of time as money is tied to pretty
specific ideas about Labor morality and
and this idea of taming the uncivilized
in tracing this history I also cite the
work of Caitlin Rosenthal who has
researched early examples of what we
would Now call spreadsheets including
pre-printed ones that were used to
record the labor of people enslaved on
American and Caribbean plantations and
for Rosenthal there is an uncomfortable
link between this history and modern
management practices
in an interview with the Harvard
Business Review she pointed out that
many of the men running these
plantations were absentee owners they
lived overseas
and she says quote so you imagine them
in London getting reports in the mail
about their plantations and just
crunching the numbers over lunch not so
different from Modern board members it's
so easy for someone at a long distance
to forget about the humanity of the
labor and then of course this
abstraction of time and measurement of
Labor continued with taylorism in
Factory labor a way of measuring and
systematizing work to make it go faster
this graphic is from an article called
the stopwatch as inventor in a 1916
issue of factory magazine and you can
see how minutely the work is broken down
into separate timed actions and this is
my personal favorite uh this is from
Harry braverman's book where he's
looking at scientific office management
and this is them timing how long it
takes to punch a Time
hard
it's very meta so in these examples what
you find is that the history of time
management well certainly Innovative has
so often been inextricable from the
desire to get more labor out of people
in less time for his part Taylor had
hoped that workers would share in the
increased productivity but that
unfortunately is not what seems to have
happened and meanwhile it continues to
morph into new oppressive forms to some
of us something like taylorism sounds
like something of the industrial past
but it wouldn't to anyone who uses a
scanner gun in an Amazon warehouse works
in a call center that uses motivational
leaderboards drives the UPS truck fitted
with sensors or Works remotely on a
computer that uses employee tracking
software unironically named staff cop
this is Staff cop
so I end the chapter by comparing the
moment my one of my favorite movie
moments ever in Charlie Chaplin's modern
times where he's strapped into a feeding
machine designed to eliminate the
factory lunch hour and he's like abused
by this corn cob going into his face
with keichi matsuda's 2019 360 degree
short film merger in which the lone
character struggling to keep up with her
work interface and an evil version of
Microsoft's clippy which you can see in
the background there
she tells us there isn't always time to
eat but there are so many innovative
ways to fuel your body and mind
so besides its survival into the present
the other reason to revisit this history
is that it makes it easier to see the
ways in which we've internalized this
very specific industrial sense of time
this is from increasing personal
efficiency of priling your library find
and it's a 1925 book that attempts to
very literally apply Taylor's principles
to one's own life and thinking so in
this view you are both Factory owner and
Factory and the hours of your life are
your material
and I trace this also to the present
specifically to a group of content
creators I refer to in the book as
productivity Bros
um
this is an image of a product called the
Mastery Journal where you are evidently
both master and mastered
logging your progress on 10-day
productivity charts so these and other
forms of time management show that the
idea is very much still alive that
everyone has 24 fungible hours in a day
and that those who fall behind simply
aren't using them in the right way and
that furthermore life is a zero-sum game
where my getting ahead can only mean
you're falling behind
instead beyond the basic psychological
variation in how time feels the shape of
your hours and days so often depends on
the same things that govern the
landscape of power in our society
Financial latitude race gender ability
zip code number of children and other
circumstantial factors from the distance
you live from your work to relationships
or lack thereof to neighbors to your
company or country's sick leave policies
one of the people I spoke to for this
book is an admin for a working mom's
Facebook group and I thought it was very
telling that rather than follow the
advice of time management self-help
which she compared to the financial
advice to just not buy that latte
she thought it might be a better idea to
get six other moms together and have
each one of them make dinner for
everyone else one night of the week
already a tacit acknowledgment of the
social nature of time
as long as we continue to subscribe to
this notion of individuals with fungible
hours in their individual time Banks
it's harder for us to imagine this kind
of collective liberating of time whether
it's in the hard sense of Labor
organizing and policy interventions or
in the soft sense of how we talk to each
other about time
when we remove the grid and the calendar
from time which I simply understand is
change and a series of interconnected
processes the temporal landscape turns
out to be incredibly rich but the
Primacy of this landscape can be a
really hard thing to grasp in chapter
four I present this graph of Sundial
time versus standardized clock time
and I write the graph shows both
readings of time yet they are not equal
Sundial time is being described in the
terms of clock time which are the given
grounds for comparison and I would say
that much of my project in this book
could be described as me trying to flip
these two both for myself and for the
reader to make material non-linear
signatures of time feel like what time
really is
so before this talk we watched that
beautiful piece the history of the sky
in the book I write about doing
something similar during the pandemic
because so much of the social
structuring of time was removed or
interrupted my days felt like as I put
in the book boxes of time to be filled
in my box of a room forever and ever
and in response to the stultifying
sameness I pointed a camera out my
window and sporadically took photos of
the sky and I Write Time felt the same
in my room but in the photos it rained
it stormed and the fog rolled in from
San Francisco sometimes the clouds were
enormous and sharply defined other times
distant and wispy midday the sky could
be a deep dark blue in the evening it
would soften to an Indescribable shade
of something like purple or pink
and as I mentioned earlier this chapter
is sort of imaginatively set in
Pescadero
I called the chapter putting time back
in its place
and it draws on the work of geologists
the philosopher Henry bergson and
Indigenous Scholars like fine deloria Jr
and Tyson yukoporta and in all of those
cases what you really sense is the
inseparability of time from space in
this chapter I use the rock layers of
the beach in which time essentially runs
sideways across the beach to illustrate
what the geologist Marcia bjornerude
calls time fullness
she writes I see that the events of the
past are still present this impression
is a glimpse not of timelessness but of
time fullness an acute consciousness of
how the world is made by indeed made of
time and trying to imagine whatever the
opposite of fungible time is I show the
reader these beach pebbles which happen
almost mid-paragraph like words
and I write look again at the Pebbles
make no mistake they are neither signs
nor symbols of time no they really are
two things at once sea floor from the
last ice age and Future Sand
so Beach or no beach simply making
everyday observations of what we
consider ecological or geological
reveals how intuitive this concrete
material sense of time Still Remains for
us and in fact I think this is exactly
what happened during the pandemic for
those whose scale of attention shrunk to
their house or their backyard
for example statistics involving birding
number of birding supplies sold number
of observations logged to sites like
eBird and visits to bird webcams show
that many more people became attentive
not only to the Daily movements of birds
but also their migrations Karina Newsome
an ornithologist and one of the founders
of blackbirders week noted that spring
migration coincided with the early
lockdowns and that it might be
therapeutic to watch the larger Rhythm
that continued to go on
in our Stillness other movements became
more palpable
for me one important clock ended up
being an individual buckeye tree in a
park that I always walk through
this tree grows leaves and flowers in
the spring and goes dormant in the late
summer but that procession is uneven
across the region across a Grove across
the branches of the same tree or across
the surface of a yellowing leaf
the body of the tree itself is also a
record of the past since the Buckeye's
ability to go dormant is an evolutionary
response to a change in the climate
three million years ago
and so I write what is a clock if it's
something that tells the time then my
Branch was a clock but unlike the clock
at home it would never return to its
original position
instead it was a physical witness and a
record of overlapping events some of
which happened long ago and some of
which are still occurring as I write
this
and that's that those images are also in
in the book this is also a text exchange
from last month when my boyfriend was
here and I was in the Santa Cruz
mountains and we're observing that the
clock is the same in both places
um Okay so
what I just described is something that
I described in the book as unfreezing
something in time
I write if you want to see some time
that isn't fungible just pick a point in
space a branch a yard a sidewalk square
a webcam and simply keep watch a story
is being written there the story is
inseparable from the story of all life
even yours
and while it might be fascinating and
enliven enlivening for us to unfreeze
things in time there is also an ethical
Dimension to doing so because to see
something as an as inhabiting time with
you is to consider that it has
experience
while researching for this book I was
really floored by a study on something
called the Lesser Minds problem that's a
what it sounds like it's a name for our
bias to see the inner lives of other
people especially people we consider to
be in out groups as not not as complex
as our own
and so in one of the experiments people
were asked to consider typically
dehumanized out groups such as drug
addicts or people without housing
ordinarily for those participants
thinking about people in those groups
wouldn't activate regions of the brain
associated with theory of mind
but what the researchers found was that
by simply asking the participants
whether or not a houseless person would
like a certain vegetable those neural
regions became activated
in other words and in my interpretation
the question about the vegetable
presumes a person with preferences and
desires and desire an attitude for the
future and a reflection of one's past
can only exist in time the time
inhabited by that person
this notion of frozenness or unfroziness
has broader implications namely
regarding the climate crisis that
increasingly interrupts the human
calendar
just like the concept of time as money
is a political history so too is the
division of who and who does not inhabit
time I.E who has experience and who acts
on the historical stage
the Jamaican theorist Sylvia winter has
written about how the Western notion of
man versus nature defined man against
colonized people who were characterized
as Timeless backward or less progress
part of the similarly Timeless landscape
and in my formulation Frozen
in that same book I mentioned earlier
the colonization of time the author
quotes a letter from the daughter-in-law
of a British missionary in what is now
South Africa in which she writes
you must know that today we have
unpacked our clock and we seem a little
more civilized
for some months we have lived without a
timepiece John's chronometer and my
watch have failed and we have left time
and been blanched onto eternity however
it is very pleasing to hear tick tick
tick and ding ding for me this suggests
an important connection that the same
framing that has allowed us to juice the
supposedly inert non-experiencing
natural world dry is the same one I
mentioned earlier in which laborers have
been Juiced of their supposedly fungible
lifetimes
it also explains why we feel that there
is cultural human time which moves
forward and makes things and natural
non-human time which is cyclical and
insubstantial it's that it's an echo of
that supposed hierarchy of The Eternity
and tick tick tick and ding ding as Bill
McKibben has pointed out the irony of
this conceptual divide is that what is
thought of as human cultural time
actually can't keep up with the changes
in what is thought of as non-human time
in that vein I argue a lot in this book
for non-human subject hood and that's
one of the reasons I Rely so much on
indigenous scholarship
like those Scholars and like McKibben my
reasoning is partly practical I really
don't believe that a true holistic
response to either time scarcity or the
climate crisis is possible without such
a change in perspective
but I also want this for us
both in how to do nothing and in Saving
Time I'm really bothered by this idea
and very much informed by my own
experience of people chasing achievement
but really wanting meaning and
connection among and Beyond the human
these are two little diagrams that I
find myself drawing different versions
of every single year and they maybe give
you a sense of what extension means in
the title of my last chapter life
extension that chapter which is really
less about mortality than what it means
to me to be alive starts with a story
from a children's book my mom got from a
garage sale it's haunted me ever since I
read it also thanks to my mom for
scanning it but basically a witch visits
an impatient young boy and gives him a
ball with a golden thread and if he
pulls the thread time goes faster
and she advises him to use it wisely as
the thread can't be put in any more than
time can go backward
predictably he pulls it too often and
patient to go home from school impatient
to marry his crush and patient to get a
job
luckily for him and because this is a
children's story The Witch returns to
the old man takes back the ball and lets
him start over again
but in our case no matter how many
dividends our time pays we do not get
that chance
as an answer to this anxiety I Look to
time a term used in disability
studies to describe the tension between
a disabled person's temporality and the
clock-based industrial timetables of
modern day Society for someone who
fundamentally cannot buy into the system
of thinking because it was not built for
them it is perhaps easier to imagine the
goal of life as something other than
performance and accumulation
there's a really beautiful chapter on
Crypt time in this book what can a body
do by Sarah hendron one of my favorite
contemporary writers and thinkers in
which she reflects on her experience
Raising a Son with Down Syndrome
the way people equate her son with his
diagnosis in a way seeing him also
outside of time illuminates for Henry
and how economic productivity and a life
lived along normative timetables and
Milestones are so deeply entwined with
the idea of human worth
but her son also demonstrates to her a
different way of being
seeing how Graham her son is categorized
but also seeing his self-understanding
and his sources of joy is what allows
hendrin to question everything about
time we've come to take for granted she
asks how long does it take or should it
take for a body to move through the
world the 40 plus Hour Work Week the
demands of caregiving for ailing parents
the daily commute of the body with its
changing needs over the lifespan
a pregnant body an aging one a body in
recovery after a bad injury
is the clock of industrial time built
for bodies at all
the idea of Krypton prepares us to move
from thinking about achievement to
thinking about encounter
I'll never forget the elderly woman who
called in to a radio show I was on
talking about how to do nothing she was
recently disabled and had been sitting
in her backyard watching the birds and
in some cases even having them land on
her and she said it was one of the
happiest times in her life
I too can attest to this phenomenon as a
related experience is almost entirely
responsible for my interest in Birds
something that's now very present in all
of my work
in the book I describe a day in 2013
when I just pulled an all-nighter on an
art project I had just come home from my
day job I was lying on my couch
immobilized by my own exhaustion with my
eyes pointed up out the window at the
top of a redwood tree I was so tired
that in fact I thought I was
hallucinating pears growing at the top
of the tree until I realized that they
were birds with yellow bellies all
facing into the sun
and this site made my burnout from work
flip over into a different kind of
tiredness an open mouth State of Wonder
that the poet Peter Hancock calls
tiredness that trusts in the world
what I had seen were cedar waxwings who
are locally nomadic and follow the
fruiting of berries an expression of
time in their own way
the site was a Gateway for me that has
remained open ever since
I write I remember that Vision on the
couch so clearly not just because it was
the beginning of an abiding interest in
birds and their territories
in a more General sense I remember it as
a kind of opening onto Infinity through
that opening I saw something else
someone else beckoning from a different
version of time and space where Suburban
Gardens far-flung wintering grounds
summer and winter were all intertwined
and I I later go on to suggest that
maybe the point isn't to live more in
the literal sense of a longer or more
productive life but rather to be more
alive in any given moment a movement
across rather than shooting forward on a
narrow lonely track
and on that note there's something I
think is implied in a lot of this book
but that I regret isn't said more
outright and which I think is especially
appropriate to mention here at the long
now
I am very fortunate to have a handful of
friends in their 60s and 70s I am also
fortunate to be friends with a couple of
my own former students
and the more time I spend with these
friends the more I let go of the idea
that generational concerns are
inherently unrelated
yes things have changed yes in this
country older Generations hold much of
the wealth but I think an overemphasis
on generational barriers makes it less
obvious how people in every group might
Harbor values that have cut across time
in history and it obscures some of the
possibilities that come with a
collective memory and a set of
experiences that are longer than any of
our individual lifetimes
in the chapter of my book on communal
languages of time
I quote quite a bit from process World a
magazine active in the 80s and 90s that
was started by a group of San Francisco
temp workers concerned about the
alienation of modern work and life
and what I especially love is the
letters section which acts almost like a
Proto Message Board allowing readers to
discover each other and the idea that
they are not alone in their
dissatisfaction the so-called honor of
getting to sell the hours of your life
for something so meaningless
one of the letters starts out jump in
Jehoshaphat there's intelligent life out
there
and I think this kind of Discovery can
happen not just across space but across
time my friend Chris Carlson one of the
editors of process world
recently wrote in an essay about his
hopes in the 1980s for the magazine
adding our ideas in our community that
shared our sensibility didn't really
grow much perhaps our role was to carry
a radical thread from the decades that
preceded us to the decades that would
follow I was so excited by this sentence
that I immediately emailed Chris to tell
him how I'd woven process World quotes
together with contemporary organizing
among International gig workers but also
how I expected my readers including a
fair share of people younger than me to
easily recognize both the fury and the
sense of humor that comes through in
process world
that's what I saw as my role and it
would be impossible not only with these
past Expressions but with institutions
like the internet archive and the
prilinger library who make them
available to the present
I think the most important technology
we've ever had is the story but stories
only work through the telling
so I'm just going to end by reading an
excerpt from that same chapter that
process World shows up in and just to
give a little bit of context because it
comes up in the excerpt I use a term
familict which I learned about from my
friend Helen So a family just means a
specific words or phrases that are used
hyper locally within a small group of
people so it's like a dialect but even
smaller earlier this year I was in the
garden of a septuagenarian friend while
she was planting some beans
she told me that they were descended
from Beans she'd gotten 20 years before
from somewhere she couldn't quite
remember maybe Home Depot I could never
find again
at the time she'd shared the beans with
friends all of whom loved them and
couldn't find them anywhere else either
but some friends let the bean pods
mature and dry out saving the beans and
giving them back to her
she had no idea how many people had them
by now and speculated that this line of
beans could have spread across the
entire country
as she planted them we mused that
although there had been a give and take
between her and her friends it was not
exactly transactional she wasn't taking
back the things she had given them
though the two were certainly related
she moved on to some lettuce beds
telling me I should take some lettuce I
thought she was just being polite but
she told me that she actually needed to
get rid of the outside leaves so the
inside leaves would keep growing before
the plant reached maturity she was
constantly giving bags of lettuce to
people she said
this simple gesture and the story of the
beans made me realize how broken my
mental mechanisms were for thinking
about anything beyond the transactional
exchange
in part this is because I've never lived
anywhere I could Garden I'd sort of
forgotten that a plant keeps growing
assuming that more lettuce for leaves
for me would mean fewer lettuce leaves
for her
would it be possible to not to save and
spend time but to Garden it by Saving
inventing and stewarding different
rhythms of life
and wouldn't this simply be an
acknowledgment and use of the Chrono
diversity that already exists for all of
us on some level individually and
communally if time can be gardened then
it's also possible to imagine its
increase in ways other than individual
hoarding
before I left my friend's Garden she
gave me some Scarlet runner beans from a
bean farm that no longer exists
they're now sitting on a metal shelf
next to the store-bought beans that Joe
and I like many other people started
stocking up on during the pandemic
I've had so much time to look at and
think about beans but I had never
considered what they actually were
I Googled can you plant store-bought
beans and the answer was yes those
things in the bags they weren't just
Commodities sure you could eat them but
they weren't end points and they weren't
dead at least some of them contained
something the possibility of future
beans
as I told more friends about this story
it became an inside joke a new familict
time is not money time is beans
it was about as serious as many jokes
are which is to say about half
saying it meant that you could take time
and give time but also that you could
plant time and grow more of it and that
there were different varieties of time
it meant that all your time grew out of
someone else's time maybe out of
something someone planted long ago
it meant that time was not the currency
of a zero-sum game and that sometimes
the best way for me to get more time
would be to give it to you and the best
way for you to get some would be to give
it back to me
if time were not a commodity then time
our time would not be as scarce as it
seemed just a moment ago
together we could have all the time in
the world
thanks
[Applause]
thank you so much
um I think the rest of you can kind of
see how when I started reading this book
I couldn't stop underlining things I
love the way it ended there kind of
redefines what a bean counter is
in this mechanized version of human and
commodified time so it's yeah perfect uh
a perfect thing and I I just I wanted to
kind of loop back around to just the way
that you work and and how do you think
you came to this idea of of observing
the things that are closest to us
hey that's a good question
this is a very weird answer but my my
mom my mom does respite care for foster
families which is basically like you're
a designated babysitter and she says
that she's noticed something with the
babies that she takes care of that was
also true of me which was that she said
if you push the stroller next to a shrub
like the babies will just like they'll
just get in it you know like they want
to grab it and like put their face in
the shrub you know
um and I think like when I was like
really little my mom actually just
noticed that I liked like I was happier
if I was outside just looking at stuff
like things that were very immediate and
she was always taking me to live theater
that she wanted me to be in theater
um
um but please run off and join the
circus yeah
um so I think like I think it just goes
way back like I think I grew up like
largely thanks to her like with the
assumption that there's going there's
something interesting in front of you
like I just assume that like I don't
feel like I need to like wait for it you
know yeah we've also been taking care of
a little baby and like babies are a
perfect naturalists and we just kind of
beat it out of them for the rest of
their lives yeah I know it's funny
because I I think I I said in an
interview recently that like the last
time people many people like remember
the sense of curiosity that like I am
clearly obsessed us with is childhood
but then later I was thinking about it
like that's not true I have friends who
have children and I think you've
re-experience it through children yeah
yeah watching them watch the world is
kind of one of the most magic things
yeah
um you know I've always as long as I've
worked on this project uh about time and
uh I've kind of shied away from dealing
with time from from the front like the
way you have and it's always kind of so
daunting to me
um and so I'm just I'm I'm wondering how
how you decided that it was it was it
was something that you could take on and
uh it's like it's just it's always so
daunting to me yeah it is
why don't I
don't know why didn't I write a book
about table tennis like
but then I know that I would find a way
to make that really complicated so like
yeah if anyone here has read how to do
nothing there's a part of how to do well
that's a part of how to do nothing where
I mentioned being in a cabin with no
reception and this and I didn't really
notice this until I found my notes way
later what I was doing in that cabin was
I was trying to write the proposal for
how to do nothing while I was in the
cabin and I found it and I had divided
the paper into and it was how to do
nothing in space and how to do nothing
in time
and then I think I just completely
forgot about like that like structure or
maybe the way it turned out ended up
being much more about space because
there's a lot of bioregionalism and sort
of like local ecology in that book so in
a way I think maybe it was just kind of
like
a seed that just didn't really it was
just there for a while
so those ideas were there and then after
how to do nothing came out like a lot of
feedback that I heard had to do with
time like people who were like I agree
with these ideas but I don't like what
am I supposed to do about the time I
don't have time
um and I like I really didn't like that
really bothered me because I like it
didn't have a good answer to that that
combined with like what that that sort
of seed from earlier kind of those
things came together
it's also just like I think I
similarly to observing things like I
think I like to write about things that
are very immediate like
combining you know things that are that
are from you know academic disciplines
and like other research with just like
the things that you experience every day
or the things that I experience every
day and so like time is just very
familiar it's like you can't get away
from it and so I think it appeals for
that reason yeah yeah and I think you
know it's interesting like
at least before the pandemic you'd often
ask people you know how are they doing
and the answer is always some form of
I'm really busy and this kind of fetus
is Jason with being overly busy and I
think the idea that you have kind of
given people an excuse to to not want to
be busy uh and that slowing down is
actually a and how and giving yourself
the time and obviously having the
privilege to have that time which I
think you mentioned in the book too that
time can often be a privilege as well
but can you say a little bit more about
our personal time and and and our the
way that we think about it that way yeah
so in that same chapter where I talk
about the increasing personal efficiency
book with the amazing weather map um and
the productivity Bros
um I I um something that I found very
useful in writing that and that's
mentioned in the chapter is this
um there's a paper by the sociologist
Hartman Rosa where he describes a
hypothetical character named Linda
um and Linda is um like a she's a
university professor she's
um she's very busy she's always she's
describes she's running around she
doesn't have enough time for her
students she doesn't have enough time
for her colleagues she doesn't have
enough time to like make dinner go to
the gym and like she just feels like a
failure because she's always running out
of time and then and he says like the
only way that she would um experience
like peace is if she went to a cabin
with no reception
um and and I was like reading this and
feel and then he says isn't this all
kind of her fault though like didn't she
bring this on herself and I felt like so
like attacked by this
um because I was like I'm Linda
um and so like I I kind of like use that
to like make this distinction between
like Linda's and non-lindas but then
there's like a gray area but I I think
it's a really I think that's kind of
what people were trying to get at like
when they were responding to how to do
nothing there's a difference between
someone who truly has no control over
their time and someone who feels like
they have no time and again I really
like there is a gray area but like the
you know for someone who actually
structurally doesn't have control over
their time like the answer does not lie
with them using their time better
like as the working mom admin like you
know was telling me but then there's
like another situation where you just
have someone who's deeply internalized
that like busyness is good
um and that like more like you just need
more all the time you always need to be
getting more more friends more
achievements like more you know and that
Linda character like needs to just chill
like basically go to the cabin yeah yeah
I think I I would say like experiment
with what feels like mediocrity
yeah yeah
yeah I mean I think what's amazing is
you know time has become you know it's
both the most valuable commodity that we
have and it's also the most easy to
waste or at least what we call wasting
right and so this
um you mentioned banking time and the
way that also the way that Western
cultures native cultures and plants and
animals you know may or may not follow
Gregorian calendars or or 12-hour time
but I wonder if we could talk a little
bit more about the way other cultures
and animals are perceiving time
yeah I mean I think it's just like it's
almost like like when you look at like
the history of how time became
standardized and and like the idea of
like the man hour and all that it's so
narrow like when you actually look at
the history of it so like contingent
that it's sort of like everything else
around that
um it just starts to look like a little
sliver instead of like the sort of the
norm and then there's like this exotic
way of like seeing time you know like
it's actually the Exotic way of seeing
time
um and so I think like something that I
really admired and the examples
um that I drew from Sand talk which is
the book by Tyson yonkaporta and also
examples from find deloria Jr are like
there's this um really Exquisite sense
of timing which I think is like a very
interesting to contrast timing with like
the idea of uniform time like timing
suggests that there's a right time that
so not all time is the same already and
then there's a there's the best time to
do something and so like I think you
know obviously in indigenous culture
there's like a deep attentiveness to
like what is happening at any given
moment and like you have to do this
thing at this time and the way that you
know this that this is going to happen
is that this other thing is going to
happen and they're all just like so
deeply intertwined it's sort of like
everything is a clock almost
um and so I think like that's
uh that feels much more I don't know
like it's real it's it's based on things
that are actually like materially
happening in the world it's not abstract
at all yeah I think one of the things
that you you also get to is this idea
that of different cycles of you know
geologic time or or climate time you
mentioned and I think one of the the
problems that we humans have with
thinking about things like the climate
crisis is that there's they're out of
scale with what we have been taught to
value in terms of time as being much
faster moving or much more proximate but
I wonder if you could talk a little bit
about that
yeah
um
verbal day uh with the red sky which I'm
sure many of us remember
um in chapter five and uh and this that
I I kept having these nightmares about
like a wall of Fire coming and then it
was like it was very uniform the way
that it moved it was like
it's coming for you it's like it's it's
like it's a like a video play hedge just
going and there's nothing you can do
about it and that's a very like linear
and uh like declinist way of looking at
it that I definitely had
um and so I think
one of the you know as I kind of tried
to like pick that apart in that chapter
I really came to appreciate the
different scales that everything related
to climate happens on like some things
happen very quickly some things happen
very slowly some things are hyper local
some things are widespread and some
things can go backwards like things can
be restored you know like things can
also like locally get better
um and so like when you like it just
really helped me to stop seeing it as
this like
you know and like and just kind of like
consider myself as like always every day
being in the midst of it like every day
just wake up I'm in the midst of it I
have to respond and like that's it it's
just day after day yeah
um less yeah I believe it is uh asks
um how does your relationship with time
that you kind of point out as deep as
you're reading is kind of deep and
complex influence the other
relationships in your life
um so it's how does one really strange
effect
um which I did not expect at all which
is that I for most of my life until
recently have identified as a loner I
was definitely felt that way as a
teenager it's like writing in my giant
Journal you know like everywhere
um and just like very Daria kind of
Vibes um
and uh and then I just kind of carried
that with me and I um and anyone here
who's a perfectionist knows that there's
something very isolating about
perfectionism it's like you alone you
gotta you have to do it all yourself and
it has to be perfect and I think as I as
a weird side effect of me talking about
you know not wanting to be my time in
your time and our time
um I recently realized that I am no
longer a loner like I I don't I'm not
saying that like I'm around people more
necessarily like maybe I am but but I
don't identify as a loner anymore I own
I identify as like a piece of different
relationships with different people and
I feel much less
um
selfish about my time like uh even if
I'm like working on something like I
just realized like how much of the work
gets done in conversations with people
and so I feel like I I really that that
idea of it not being a zero-sum game
like it really
affected me and like I I don't I don't
see myself as this like isolated thing
anymore right yeah well and I love how
you talk about how you know traveling uh
you know through the Circuit of the Bay
Area is can be tied to the stories that
you tell and I remember the story of
native storytelling where somebody was
in the back of a pickup truck and then
the natives who are in the back of the
truck kept starting stories and then
starting a new one because the truck was
moving much faster than a human would
and so they couldn't they couldn't
separate the time and the and the space
yeah because you need the landmarks to
right tell the story yeah so it's kind
of you did the same thing in your book
which I thought was really beautiful
yeah it did and that was like I knew
about those kinds of examples and I also
uh
um the partner of the person who gave me
the lettuce
um he and I went on a really long walk
one time in the town in the Santa Cruz
mountains we had this amazing
conversation it was very long and I I
wish that I could take notes uh that
would be weird weird to do but
um
I I realized I could remember it later
if I just went on the walk in my head
yeah so I was like let's just do that
yeah yeah that's the old trick yeah
um let's get apropos for this next
question
um do you have any inner conflict with
living in a city uh if so could you
share a bit about how you reconcile the
kind of beauty of being at a cabin with
no reception but also
clearly you're you're so very tied to
Urban culture as well yeah
yeah well for me if I lived in maybe any
other
I live in Oakland uh
yeah uh and I remember actually when I
started birding I looked at a map it was
a book of maps of California a different
um
like species diversity of like different
groups of species um and so there was
one that was like bird diversity and it
was all so clustered like it was the the
color it was like very dark um in in
Oakland and I remember like realizing
that
because I had no contacts I just thought
that there were this many birds
everywhere but like no I just like sort
of came into awareness like in a place
that happens to have a lot of birds
um and so part of the reason I like I I
sort of reconciled for me is that I live
somewhere that has
you know it has parks and there's just
like a lot I like when I get asked if I
go bird watching I I don't go bird
watching I'm just always bird watching
because if I leave my apartment I will
see birds like I see lots of birds so I
saw them today like you know
um so I think uh you know I like to make
my occasional trip to the mountains
um which we're also very fortunate to
live like pretty close to the Santa Cruz
mountains so I've gotten or I've gotten
around that problem that way I think I I
don't know I don't know what I would do
if I live somewhere else yeah I can't
move
nice and I think you know I mean the
other thing that we have here in the Bay
Area is obviously this kind of uh and
even some of the founders of long now
were uh some of the people that helped
design the first spreadsheets and things
that you kind of mentioned in here that
have driven us into kind of
commodification of time and obviously
the the culture of the way we run
companies here is is also about
um not only compress compressing time
but also this idea that there's an
infinite scaling that's possible
um but I I think you get to this a
little bit and kind of the that's we
can't just scale everything in all
directions as as humans all the time and
we have to kind of pick a right size of
things
um so I wonder if you talk a little bit
about that there's a
Daniel Wildcat who's an indigenous
author that I cite in the putting time
back in its place chapter
um where he he's sort of one he says
that he wonders like what
what would happen if we were more aware
of the personality of places that like
each place has a personality
um and as someone who grew up in um San
Jose like Cupertino San Jose with lots
of uh Anonymous shopping centers
um like that where everything sort of
like all of the difference seems to have
been paved over I recognize that it's
like hard
um in some places to see the personality
or the character of a place but I am
very enchanted with this idea that no
place is the same like the same way that
no moment is the same like no place is
the same and so I think there's like
some and that that's what gives meaning
to a place and so I think like anything
that anything that can allow us to be
more attentive to that and kind of
collect things around
the the characteristics and the
personalities of places is very
compelling to me and Kristen asks uh
what do you see as part of composing and
driving the human compulsion to capture
times this kind of goes back to your
previous book of that we seem to want to
Capture Moments in time with cameras and
and making a tweet about a thing rather
than just sitting there and experiencing
it
um yeah I mean I don't see that as a
I think it's very understandable it's
like time is always slipping through
your fingers you want to grab onto it
like what could be more human than that
you know
um I mean as someone who
uh has always written a lot in a journal
um since I was a child I have at times
asked myself like if I should just stop
writing and go outside and like do the
things that are then being written about
like like what's the what's the like
yeah what's the Divide there
um and Barbara aaronreich who wrote
natural causes I can't remember the
subtitle but it's really good it's like
killing ourselves to live longer
epidemic of Wellness that is a long
really good subtitle and it's a grim
reaper running on a treadmill
um
my uh my agent told me that she wanted
originally to call it old enough to die
and they wouldn't let her but
um that wasn't gonna fly off the shelves
let's use that phrase somewhere in the
book though I think but anyway she uh
that book is an amazing kind of
examination of that like what is the
calculus of like how much time should
you put into
trying to have more time you know and
like at what point like you know don't
you need to eventually ask the question
of like what it's all for right
um and so I think like that's I just
think it's very natural like I have that
like we everyone want if you're
especially if you're like enjoying your
life you like want more of it and you
want to
have more of it like have more like
evidence of it and it's there's
something very Bittersweet about the
idea of having a really lovely
experience that's just going to be over
like it's just going to be gone and like
you don't have anything ephemeral yeah
but then at the same time that gives it
so much meaning so yeah
yeah
um this is a good segue to Noah's
question which is uh has researching for
and writing this book changed your
feelings around aging and mortality I
know your last chapter is kind of about
this to some extent yeah yeah it is yeah
I mean it doesn't make me like it
doesn't
it doesn't make me less
uh afraid of my own death I guess
um I but I do think that
um
it has and it it's partially as a result
of writing this book but also as I
mentioned having friends who are older
um like it has allowed me to like rest
more in the time that I'm in like the
part of the my life that I'm in because
like you know the my lettuce French is
twice my age
um and like I see her see where I am and
she just sees all this time in front of
me and like I just feel like it's today
and I need you know and I'm probably
thinking about like the past week and
maybe the next week you know but like
she sees me as like situated in the
middle of something and then if I see
myself from her perspective I'm like oh
I need to really
like live this because I'm not going to
get another chance you know yeah
well that's I we have another question
that's along that lines of you know what
what nuggets of Hope might you give to
individuals stuck and Paralyzed by the
isolation and individualization uh which
is reinforced to us in the way that kind
of time has forced on us at this point
[Music]
those diagrams that I showed I I draw I
feel like I draw them over and over
again I always think it's a different
diagram but it's the same one
um and I think that if you it's hard
uh because everything about our culture
really wants to reinforce the boundaries
around yourself
but if you can try to like let go of
that
um and really like shift your focus from
these like supposed individual entities
to ties between them like what happens
when you're with a friend and like you
you and friend combined like that is
something in and of itself
um and there's there's an exchange
that's happening in there like the you
know the beans going back and forth
um I think like things like asking for
help it's like just if you're you're
having a problem as an individual and
you ask someone for help like that is in
in the Zero Sum like kind of zerosome
game view that's you're asking someone
to give you
some like they'll have less but that is
actually how most like friendships are
built is like you ask someone for help
and they help you and they want to help
you and like it's understood that you
will then help them so I think like try
it's hard like I said it's we're so you
know
um used to thinking of like not wanting
to you know bother other people or like
I'm just gonna like handle my stuff and
like you handle your stuff but I think
if you kind of start to think like what
what is possible between me and blink
like other person like place you know
well I think you get to this in a lot of
ways
um this idea of maybe an attention
economy that's different than an empathy
economy
um where you know it's less about how
much attention we can get for ourselves
or give to something but more about how
much
empathy and and feeling we can give it
to something but that was kind of one of
the things that struck me as reading
this just like hit me really hard like
yeah we need more empathy and less
trying to argue over attention yeah I
mean just think about the difference
between getting a lot of engagement on a
post online versus like your friend
wrote you a letter
and you sit down and you read the letter
it's from one person you know like that
feels so different
um and it's like and it's because they
wrote it for you
um it's it's like I had I had a friend
make me a podcast once which is just for
me
it was great you know
um what a luxurious thing yeah it had a
whole part at the end that was just like
birds in Prospect Park like amazing
um yeah yeah oh that's beautiful
um right I think you know your kind of
definition of time that you mentioned at
the beginning that you know it's this
thing that bubbles up and is all around
us and rather than a thing that we're
that is washing over us or moving past
us
um I think is that's a liberating way to
think about time in a lot of ways it
gives it gives people a lot more freedom
I think yeah and I do think it works
against that isolation um
quote in chapter four from from Henry
bergson who's talking about
um he's describing walking through a
city that he has been in for many years
and it's familiar to him and then he
sort of has this realization that
everything that he's seeing around him
has also aged and he says like like you
know he's describing the things and he
says like like me they have aged and I
like I think about that sentence like so
often like when I'm looking around like
that you're there if everything is
Frozen in time except for you or for
humans or the humans you care about
um that's a very lonely existence it's
like the other things aren't speaking
back to you they're not
with you in time but if everything you
know everything like you has aged
um and it's all aging together and it's
you know everything is affecting
everything else like that's that's not
lonely to me even if I'm alone right to
kind of wrap up
um I I know that you are probably
daunted by the fact that your book just
came out today and it's really great
seeing how much praise it's getting and
that you're probably going to be asked
to give lots and lots of talks like this
so we're so glad to have you at the
beginning of it but I'm wondering if you
uh if you have thoughts on already on
maybe what you're going to be working on
next
no way that you can
think that much about time and not end
up thinking about memory but memory is
not really it's not really treated in
the book I mean I am sort of arguing
that like rocks have memory and like you
know experience is memory but
um but memory specifically is very
interesting to me now and also what
counts as memory like I'm reading a
rereading uh Ed Young's book right now
um an immense World which is about
animal senses and he has this
description of uh what it's like to be a
dog and that there's all these there's
there's a record of all these the dog is
basically reading like texts in the form
of smell of all the things that have
happened and so it's like the air is
just crisscrossed with these memories
right like they're not human memories so
I I think like the sort of a memory as a
trace like and the fact that there are
traces of things happening everywhere
that's what's currently interesting to
me nice well you you did a great job of
painting time as a palace in this book
and that I think I would I can't wait to
get into the Memory Palace with you so
thank you so much thank you
thank you
[Music]